[Music]  Shawn Mendes reveals how old he was when  he lost his virginity the 19 year old  singer dropped by New Zealand radio  station the edge on Friday where he  played a game filled with some  hilariously invasive questions  [Music]  the one catch if Sean refused to answer  one of the hosts would get an electric  shock to the nipple who was the last  celebrity you kissed like II for the  host there were a few intimate details  the mercy singer was willing to share  what is the oldest lover you hit hit cut  20 20 25 how old were you at the time 19  ads for the million dollar question Sean  and it's a hell were you when you lost  your vape late 16 what's the legal age  in Canada it's extinct rating and there  now I 18 yes  [Music]  you